[Music]
such a drain yes I'll just shut up
drain shut now that scene is from the TV
show Will & Grace smart home devices
like the shower that you're looking at
are becoming more popular they taught
many holiday wish lists it's estimated
there are now more than 1 billion
Internet connected devices in homes
across North America and that number
we're near were nearly double by 2025
but each smart device comes with a
security risk they say CBS News
contributor and editor-in-chief of Wired
that's Nick Thompson is back at the
table
good to see you Nicholas to see you Gail
hello so I'm good
so what I'll actually I'm not good but
that's another story why should people
care if you can hack into your
refrigerator or your vacuum cleaner why
should we care about that what
information you're getting so the risk
is not just that a hacker will make too
many ice cubes the risk is that there is
stored on those devices and get on your
location and perhaps whether you're
there at that time and then not only
that if a hacker can get onto one device
it's possible that it can be a foothold
to get on your whole Wi-Fi network or
perhaps to get on your phone through
that devices app and once they're there
lots of other things can happen in a
common type of attack is called a botnet
what is that
so a botnet is when hackers attack a
whole bunch of devices like they figure
out the default password for all the
refrigerators and then they use those
refrigerators essentially as computers
to attack other machines around the
internet so it's not actually something
that harms you but last year when the
whole internet went down those guys a
botnet attack tied I believe to an old
VCR is connected to the Internet so what
happens is all of these smart home
devices right they come with default
passwords when you get them and a lot of
them don't have real security baked into
them because they're low margin devices
made by tons of manufacturers and so
often they come with the same password
for all the devices Anthon hacker can
very easily get into all of them how
would you know they were hacked yeah
well you probably people start talking
to you
no question and it's very hard to tell
you might be able to tell if you're good
at analyzing your router traffic you
might notice a slowdown across all of
your devices one thing that I do one
security precaution there are lots of
security processes but one thing I do is
I unplug my router every time I go away
for the weekend just in case something
on it has been compromised just take
those things offline make them reset
come back in Monday plug it back in at
least limit some of that what can happen
do with that data
yeah well they can do all kinds of bad
things right so they can run a big
botnet which doesn't really affect you
but is bad for the world they can figure
out whatever information you've stored
on the device and if they get to another
device then they have a camera inside
your home that's not good at all they
can find your passwords that's not good
at all so the steps you should take to
protect yourself like I said you can
unplug things yeah you shouldn't connect
devices you don't use you have some old
device connected to your internet and
you haven't used it in two years just
unplug it
you should change the default password
and you should update the software on
all these devices whenever you can basic
security steps you'll be ok do you still
think they're a good thing right before
Christmas are they good gifts I love
them I mean smart homes are awesome
right it is so cool what you can do with
all these devices but there are yeah the
problem is that the tech has come really
fast right it's just a couple years and
because it's low margins so many
manufacturers so confusing we don't have
security so what needs to happen we need
to kind of take care of our devices and
protect ourselves and then the
manufacturers need to start building
better security into them recognizing
how important it is but still this stuff
super cool yeah go for it Nick always
good to see you thank you so much to you
thank you all right